now you got to know this about my wife
my my wife is is a highly trained highly
experienced highly skilled martial
artist she's very good okay that sounds
racist not like she's a samurai I mean
no cuz that's Japanese she's Chinese
that's
[Applause]
[Music]
racist
perfect perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect what's up everybody I am
Thomas dope asol whatever you want to
call me this is the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neal what's up guys what's up this is
the dope as usual podcast here talk
about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between today we have comedian Brad
Williams hello sir thank you for being
here I love the fact that it's a weed
podcast and you throw a dwarf on it
that's going to trip your your viewers
out just like holy crap it kicked in
early question yeah do you smoke weed
yes oh you do yes we weren't super sure
usually we have monsters yeah I wasn't
sure I won't smoke on the podcast just
cuz I got to uh Drive later be a be a
dad like function as an adult which I
don't do well on weed and I always tell
that to people and they go no man you
got to find the right strand like
there's like energy drink weed or
something like that I'm like like not
not not for me like that's called
cocaine yeah exactly I want to do that
adult weed cocaine yeah exactly um I I
like I said we're in the weed space
there are some I don't I it's like oh
this liquor gets you awake but you're
still drunk as [__] yeah exactly so it
doesn't really work right yeah and I and
I and I got to go back and stare at my
daughter and I don't want to be thinking
about the universe and I just want to be
looking at her and be like all right
cool we're good and I don't want her to
look at me and go what's wrong with
daddy cuz how old is your uh almost four
yeah oh she's coherent she's a human
already Yes we had to stop cursing a few
months ago cuz we're like oh you repeat
stuff now okay where' you find out at uh
oh thankfully just an Adele Taco
drive-thru which Stoners will appreciate
that but uh yeah just an Adele just an
ad Del Taco drive-thru she said some
words that I was uh screaming at uh the
at the NFL football Sunday so uh yeah
you sound like this guy yeah now have
you had any like embarrassing moments
where your kid is saying something to
somebody in public that's like
horrifying uh not yet we haven't had
that uh yet but she does oh wait no
never mind yes we we did have that so uh
uh this was in a we were just at the
store and this was in her Blues Clues
phase uh and she had a little toy
there's a character on that show called
tickity talk right so she has this Toy
That's The tickity Talk this little he's
a little clock and she dropped the toy
as as we pushing the cart and then out
loud she remember it's time she's like 2
and a half and she just starts yelling
out I lost my [__] oh my God I lost my
[__] and now everyone's like looking at
this 2-year-old Asian dwarf baby and and
just saying I lost my [__] and then but
thankfully I live in Southern California
so I'm like it's okay she's transgender
and everyone was just likeo okay very
okay very Progressive that's fine we
have no problems with that whatsoever
you know yeah so it's fine it's good but
yeah that that was and then my wife got
really mad at me for saying that out
loud uh so I so I imagine she'll hear
about this on the podcast be like why
did you tell that story We I'm like I
don't know funny that's a triple threat
I can't yeah what can I say to you yeah
yeah hold on hold on can you explain to
him why you're the Megatron you're going
to be the Megatron of racist jokes the
Megatron of racist jokes I say whatever
I want basically is as soon as I have a
child my wife's Asian yes good right I'm
Mexican same hey asan Club all Grandma's
Jewish other grandma's German
okay stepdad was a whpr assist step my
supremacist two prison Birds wow it's a
long story your prison baby not my real
dad but's all right well he's Ned
Flanders remember when Ned Flanders
takes his shirt off yeah but covered in
white is Right Pride oh wow okay one of
those and and and and and does he still
practice does he still practice love
that does he still practice the white
supremacy uh probably in there yeah they
it's like a temple in there so they have
to pray every day okay so he so so he's
back all right so the whole uh where he
should be so the whole uh uh uh we
rehabed him that didn't work no no
rehabs out here we come and get a little
like oh God Taco Bell
yeah I just go back in for8 years okay
yeah on but yeah as soon as I have a
baby like hey I can say anything I want
you got you got to you got to adopt a
black kid because that's like and then
that's the last thing I and then hope
the black kid is trans and then you'll
and then you'll and then you'll have
everything and then you then you're just
good see right now I've got uh I've got
Asian and dwarf that's what I've got so
those those are the jokes I'm allowed to
make uh but yeah if you adopt a trans
black baby oh you're you're ad trans
black baby yeah like like when you go to
the adoption agency you be like can I
can I request a trans do you have any
Progressive yes babies like really
open-minded babies you know I think
that'd be great yo that skit would be
hilarious you're just yeah you're like
the old Seinfeld episode where you're
just going for the Joe Community like
like you're you're just going to we like
no no I got that covered I'm fine that's
I I I like the plan and then you'll have
the longest hyphenated special name of
all time because the you're if you ever
do a comedy special you'll have to
hyphenate everything just be like and so
everyone knows hey these are my
bonafides and of of all of why I'm able
to say this horrible stuff so I like not
fight me yeah fight me after yeah I like
it you can have a real career on your
hand yeah no no it's going to be 16
seconds I'm going to get heckled and I'm
going to lose my shin yeah that yeah
yeah that sometimes have you ever seen a
comedian get in a fight a fight like
from an Heckler bro come on man wait
this is real i' never never once I've
asked how many comedians have we asked
not one story really not one they're
lying I asked what we asked fluffy as
Josh Wolf we asked Brian Ken not one not
one not one I said nobody's ever got a
fight I'd be pissed I've seen multiple
like this is not one like they really
there was one on World Star this week
actually come on yeah I saw that one
yeah it's like dude I I came up in the
open mic scene in Southern California
which uh I think yeah fluffy did too cuz
he was in Long Beach uh yeah I saw
plenty uh I I want to go on stage cuz my
opening act was about to get into a
fight and I had to calm everything down
uh not my current opening act my current
opening act is a uh great comic named JB
ball he's fantastic and no this was an
opening act way back in the day but um
yeah I had to like go out and like be
like hey I know I'm I'm I I you're not
supposed to be see me for another 15
minutes but let me calm this [__] down
uh that yeah that was a fun time uh
there's been multiple times where we've
almost seen fights
UMC all right so my opening act now JB
ball like I said great comic black guy
we are on a streak and him him and I
laugh about it every week every week
someone calls him the nword
and the club yeah not like not not an
employee of the clubs but like some
audience member cuz we do meet and
greets afterward every week it happens
always a white guy and he's always just
looking at him daring him essentially to
do something about it it's sucks it
sucks it having a having a black opening
act there are multiple times when I look
at him cuz he's next to me during the
meet and greet and he's selling his
stuff I'm selling my stuff there's
multiple times where I look over at him
like holy [__] people say that to you
and then there's multiple times and he
looks over me and goes holy [__] people
say that to you like that happens
constantly are they trying to be funny
cuz he's a comic or are they being mean
yeah no they're being funny funny
hilarious joke you what is that start
hey you sp like yeah love you man so
good so funny never heard that before
how's he react to that uh he sell he
sells them a T-shirt and he and he takes
their money which I'm full fan of yeah
i' I'd kick a guy out last week cuz uh
yeah he did that uh during my Set uh he
referenced JB and and JB doesn't do any
like I don't want to say nword material
he he doesn't do any stuff that I would
look at as like holy crap I I I could
see why that would piss off who racists
but like he's not like he's not doing
that kind of material so it's amazing to
me that uh people have just started to
let fly I I don't know what's the cause
of it I don't know how how they feel
empowered or emboldened or ideas that
they think that's going to be a good
idea I know what I know what I'll do to
get this black guy to like me I'll call
him the worst possible thing I can it's
very interesting so I'm not saying I'm
going to see a fight soon JB is uh uh uh
very poised but uh I I might see an
audience member fight another audience
member I've had a brawl a fullon brawl
happen at my show one time
what sparked it uh I'll tell you so this
is crazy here we go so I was at and this
is one of the best clubs in the country
and it's in a uh it's in a wealthy part
of town and so this does not happen here
there are clubs where if you told me hey
a fight happened there I'd be like yeah
it's Tuesday like that that that's what
happens at that particular Club this
club it's at uh the Comedy Works in
Denver the South the South Club one of
the best clubs in the country run so
professionally um
what happened was is a large group of
people uh came to the show they were I I
still remember it back right corner and
we found this out later uh when the cops
came uh but so
the uh uh uh the oh
so the girl was with a guy and the girl
was cheating on the guy with his friend
and she decided to tell him that
midow midow I don't know what sparked it
I don't know what sparked her to be like
by the way I'm [__] Rick like I don't
know what happened there but she did and
just brawl brawl happen blood flying
everywhere it was it chairs flying and
like I had a friend of mine uh who was
at that show and that was his first time
seeing a comedy show and he's like does
this happen at every com no this is not
typical but yeah uh uh yeah oh there was
one time uh one time a bouncer grabbed a
guy from one of my shows and uh used his
head as a battering ram and uh to open
the door one time in Buffalo your
hometown right okay Buffalo th this was
fun cuz my wife was with me and uh I was
great I was dating her at the time and
now you got now you got to know this
about my wife my my wife is is a highly
trained highly experienced highly
skilled martial artist she's very good
okay not sound racist not like she's a
samurai I mean no cuz that's Japanese
she's Chinese that's
racist hold on I didn't know yeah
exactly you're fine uh which like her
main uh discipline is a Korean martial
art so everything's everything's up in
the air so so yeah but she she's not
like okay I go for defense ladies hiya
like no she's do not do not [__] with
her and so this when we were dating and
she came out to Buffalo cuz you know I
really wanted to seal the deal show her
one of the great cities of our country
Buffalo and um there uh I did this story
it was it it appeared in one of my
specials uh where I talk about going
overseas and doing shows for the troops
doing a bunch of Uso shows and I'm doing
that and there's a drunk lady in Buffalo
I know right uh yeah light alcoholism
yeah oh so much and the and the roast
beef on whack doesn't doesn't absorb the
alcohol it he knows it's called roast
beef on wack yeah that sounds dumb no
it's a good sandwich okay I'll I'll I'll
I'll stand up for the WX anyway so uh
I'm I'm telling this story and the story
is very the jokes are very pro-military
very cuz they took a they took great
care of me over there and I had a great
time and I I'm looking to go back but
she was drunk as hell and just heard me
talk about the military just stands up
and goes [__] yeah my son is over there
right now and I'm like okay great
wonderful I'm sorry I didn't perform for
him you
know and then she goes like and she
doesn't hear that she just hears
something else she just [__] you you
[__] I [__] and I and I I go
well I'm glad he's over there cuz he's
you know he's over there for our
freedoms including your freedom to be a
[__] and that wasn't the right thing to
say apparently cuz she just starts
yelling at me and uh uh uh you know
calling me a midgets and all all this
other stuff and then I see my wife from
the corner of my eye get up and she
starts moving towards her Direction and
I'm like no no no no no no no this is
not going to go well cuz cuz if my wife
fights it it it it's not a subdue you're
done okay and she's coming over to this
lady and I'm just like whoa so now I'm
I'm I'm trying to stop her I'm I'm
trying to stop my wife I'm I'm literally
calling out to my wife like do not do
this do not I got this we're fine as
this is happening the bouncer at the
club uh there uh in the club is Helium
Comedy Club in Buffalo he is a he's a
very large black man and his real name
is Will Smith that's his real name and
uh apparently Will Smith if your name
Will Smith you have a physical
convertation in your life uh cuz he just
walks over and in one scoop yoink just
picks up the drunk lady and just walks
out and uh apparently I found out later
he just put her down on the curb called
uh called whoever she needed to call
because she had other friends and family
like in the show and and and she was
calling to them like come on we're
[__] leaving and then they're like no
we're having fun we're going to stay
here and enjoy the show get home safe Ma
so she's the shitty friend of the group
yeah yeah yeah yeah those are my
absolute favorites uh that happened
again uh when I took the guy out for
yelling out a uh something really racist
at the show um when I kicked him out and
then he then all his friends were at the
table and all his friends were like no
we don't we don't like that guy that
much like we're going to stay here and
enjoy the comedy show we'll be friends
with the racist later but like right now
we knew coming in yeah right now there's
a dwarf telling jokes we paid good money
for these tickets we paid we we paid for
a babysitter we're going to enjoy this
so yeah so the fact that no no other
comedians like I've seen a f I've seen
so many fights so many fight cooler show
I got it's sometimes like one time when
I was in Cleveland that was fun uh when
I was in Cleveland this wasn't a fight
but uh it it involved the physical
physical act um I was in Cleveland and
there was a lady uh uh who who laughed
and and when she laughed she threw her
head back back to laugh and when she did
that her hair went into a a candle that
was using re that was using real fire
and this lady had a lot of product in
her hair because I don't know if you
remember the Simpsons where they had the
the Flaming Mo episode oh yes yes the
yeah cuz every time you light it it go
it would light on fire that was her hair
or she just leaned back and laughed and
all of a sudden I see a fireball go up
in the audience and I'm just like what
is happening and then um the men at her
table get up get their napkins and start
beating her to try to throw the fire out
me me meanwhile one of the other dates a
very intelligent woman just grabs a
water and goes like it just puts the
fire out but yeah oh I've had some crazy
stuff happen to shows come on nobody has
a story you had a woman catch on fire
yeah combusted yes I've had that no
one when Comics said I haven't seen a
fight I'm like what rooms are you doing
that I'm not and I don't find myself was
a very like I I try I try to be
everyone's Friend on stage I'm not
trying to be agitator I'm just trying to
have a good time uh so I I I I don't
think it's my crowds I just think it's I
don't know so I've I've been tour I've
been doing this for 20 years you're on
the road so much a lot of averages
you're going to get Gabriel hasn't seen
a all right I got to text Gabriel I got
I I got to text Fluffy and be like
you're lying you've seen some [__] seen
especially being over here in East LA
and boil FES you got see someone get
jumped in at least one time yeah
something has there been a time
allegedly when your wife has put hands
on somebody and the the Nazi are coming
uh correct uh I I told this story This
was um this is on my Netflix special the
degenerates now if you want to watch my
new special why I'm here uh I have I
have a new special called starfish that
is coming out December 21st on veps V PS
now if you're like Brad I don't want to
subscribe anything else you don't have
to subscribe just go there there's
plenty of amazing concerts and uh uh
Laney Wilson just did a concert on there
and there's concerts and there's
Comedians and you can just watch
concerts and comedy specials so you can
watch mine starfish it comes out
December 21st why December 21st that's
the winter solstice the shortest day of
the year okay now plug back to the story
yes the shortest daily it's a I'm a
marketing layers did you think of that
did you realize that come on come on
layers on top of each other so
uh this was in Las Vegas and I told the
story of my special but I'll tell a
slightly more detailed version here with
you guys so uh it was at the MGM Grand
it was at a a bar called The Whiskey
down it's still there great bar uh and
there was a guy there and he started
hitting on my wife and this is when she
was my wife and uh yeah uh he's hit he's
hitting on her and she's being very kind
she's being more than gracious and
patient with this dude saying like hey
not interested this is my husband like
and then he looks and sees me and now my
my wife is not a little person she's
tall uh and she's she's a she's a very
attractive Chinese woman and uh he could
not believe that uh this very attractive
tall Chinese woman was with uh this guy
so uh which trust me I wake up every day
and I can't believe it but he uh
vocalized it and uh he said some very
very mean things to me and then turned
back to her and said some some very mean
things to her and uh then uh that then
the next thing he knew he was waking up
she knocked him out oh a foot right to
the face she kicked him in the face yeah
yo your wife where did you meet her
where where did this happen this is
insane all right you want to hear this
story then I do want to hear this story
what so this story I met my wife when I
was in San Francisco California uh and I
met her on an app uh called field now if
you go to your phones right now
and type in field you're like oh I know
hinge I know coffee Meats bagel I know
Farmers Only what's field field is uh
for people that are trying to have uh
three-ways cool so that yeah so oh
playing the field yeah yeah exactly uh
so that's the sound of everyone logging
off and uh going to their phones right
now and downloading the app but uh yeah
so uh I met I I was on that app I
matched with two women one of the women
did not show up on the date I'm guessing
cuz she looked at my profile and was
like oh his whole body fits the default
photo uh so she didn't show up but I
went on a date just with my wife then
and uh you know I this lady and then two
two years to the day of that I proposed
to her because when you find a hot Asian
that is down for three ways lock that up
that's never going to get better so it's
a bumper sticker yeah job yeah did that
people were like why did you settle down
I'm like cuz that that's what I found
and I yeah I found the freaking unicorn
which is also another term uh that area
but yes uh yeah so that that's how I met
this amazing
woman great I got dude I got stories for
days man I got I got stories for days
now to be fair and and my wife will get
mad at me unless I say this uh she she
has used the martial art one time she
was about to use it on that lady but she
is a very patient very patient person
when once you've reached reached a
certain level of that discipline I found
like you don't get to be a fourth Dawn
black belt because you randomly kick
people's ass she is good because she's
patient and I I'm friends with a few
people in the MMA Community Fighters and
stuff and they are very similar like
you're not that high ranking if you're
just going out to bars and look looking
to hurt people you're you're there for
the right reasons you you you respect
the art if something happens and you
have to use the art okay but that's not
what uh that's not what she looks for I
will put that qualifier out there so I
can go home and not get beat up be safe
yeah people like Brad is it scary being
on stage and I'm like I sleep next to a
black belt in a pitbull I'm not scared
of the stage okay I'm both of both of
those things at any point my wife or my
dog if they woke up today and thought
you know what today I choose death for
Brad I would have no choice in the
matter I I'm not defending myself
against the pit bull or the black belt
wife like I can't so yeah uh yeah so I I
I sleep very comfortably and I don't
fear being on stage stage is great stage
stage is fine I got a weapon at least on
stage up here yeah yeah exactly yeah
dude so our house some some some people
are gun people and I won't get into the
gun debate on the podcast that's for you
guys to talk talk about we never ever
will yeah um but uh my house is full of
w weapons but uh uh not guns my like now
a random donatell bow staff might come
out from underneath the table that's her
weapon of expertise uh whoa his wife's
April O'Neal no April couldn't use the
bow app no I'm saying now we're talking
about some cool [__] know all that stuff
dude and then uh a fan brought me this
and now I have this hidden in my house
somewhere so if I ever have to grab it
uh a fan brought me a homemade uh
shalele which is like an yeah my dad
used to have one of those in the back of
the station wagon yeah like what what
was the original purpose for those do
you know it's a it's a death hammer for
people it's a death Hammer okay death
Hammer by the way young Stoners out
there if you're if you're looking for a
name of your band death Hammer that's
great I I'm definitely seeing them in
ozfest uh so yeah so a guy handmade a
death hammer and gave it to me uh and
then he put spikes on the staff so like
if I'm swinging this thing it's
ridiculous do not break into my house
that's I always don't come in don't
don't do it you get past the pit boy you
get past the wife yeah then you got to
deal like then your final boss is a
dwarf with a death Hammer which I mean
sounds like a Bruce Lee movie Game of
Death yeah like if you play if you play
Double Dragon back in the day there'd be
a dwarf with
a oh wait so that's so that's another
story I'll tell cuz someone did break at
my house one time uh this was way before
I met my wife this years ago so I this
back when I was living alone and uh
someone someone broke into the house and
this while I was sleeping and uh I heard
the noise and I heard my alarm go off
and I was like damn it like I'm I I had
two different thoughts I go do I just
hop in the closet and just let them take
whatever they want I go no this is my
house I'm paying [__] mortgage here
this is my first house I'm doing some
[__] so on my wall I had uh
I it's funny because I'm mared to an
Asian woman now I had an Asian phase of
like
decorating uh back in the day like you
know a bunch of I'm glad I never got one
of those Chinese tattoos of like no it
means happiness and it's like no that
means you're a power bottom uh so yeah I
never went that far douchy but I did
have I I there was a lot of bamboo let's
just say that um so I had a pair of
samurai swords on my dresser and I go
all right let's go so I grab the swords
I unsh them and I run downstairs and uh
this was a this is a twole little condo
and I run downstairs and I see the dude
he's in the house he's he's like trying
to rip my TV off the wall and I just
yell at him go get the [__] out of my
house and he just sees me and bolts and
he takes off
and right after he left I started
laughing hysterically because I
understood what this guy experienced in
his mind he broke into a house an alarm
went off and then a [__] with swords
ran out half naked by the way I was just
wearing boxers a half naked [__] with
swords runs out and he's like what
security
system what's kind of Mr Burns like
release the hounds like what what [__]
is this so yeah I still laugh about that
to that day I'm that guy probably tells
the craziest stories that guy is on
drugs outside somewhere if you're
ripping a [__] TV off the wall yeah
if he if he wasn't on drugs then he
definitely started that night he he
definitely lit it up so yeah I've got
some stories bro that is the second
Simpsons reference you you've given us
right now no I I love it that I try all
right so now just me and him we tried it
like when is a person we're trying to be
humans if not I'm just doing this cuz my
my Ed and I'm just talking about
remember the Simpson Mr Burns was hello
he was the and it'll just keep going 20
minute Tang it right so at some point
that means I got to reference a
three-eyed fish challenge
accepted I'll do it man question since
you're Simpsons fan when did when did
you what season did it fall off
to did it fall off here's the thing
about The Simpsons is yeah I don't watch
like it was required viewing back in the
day Sunday night new episodes you knew
and then and then throughout the week
he'll be playing tons of reruns um but
like every now and then I'll check in
with the Simpsons and I'll watch like a
new
episode wild still got it in my opinion
think in my opinion still got it saw
Homer hit a bong really I W I turned it
on what season am I in holy crap smoking
weed really yeah I mean I know he went
on he went on an iasa trip in the movie
but uh yeah like spider pig good movie
it's good movie man yeah exactly forget
about it where's the number two 30 years
35 years seasons why not why not you
know uh Hank's area needs more money so
uh let's get him I think he stopped yeah
he stopped being a poo he stopped being
a poo but he still like nine other
characters oh I didn't realize that yeah
he's the voice of Mo uh oh yeah you're
right he is the voice of Mo yeah they
all they all have multiple characters
characters it it's it's great it's great
for that cast man that's 35e job oh my
God like burage perfect I got The
Simpsons yeah I would do if you said
what's like top five jobs in Show
Business I'd be like all right number
one has got to be Simpsons like if
you're a voice on The Simpsons that's
just been a steady paycheck great
paycheck great residuals 35 years
whatever no no number two Jimmy Kimmel's
uh parking guy uh g g yeah that dude
that dude if I could have any job and
show business oh I just hang next to
Kimmel I I I I say yes sir Mr Y and I I
say that and then I appear in some skits
and and every now and then you know I I
get to meet famous celebrities and his
Lin's pretty much consist of yes over
and over over that's it and now and now
you got your paycheck oh what what
happened is the scenario I see he goes
to work like this guy's just the coolest
nicest no he can't talk can't speak
English but just [__] film him great
it's great it it that that that's that's
the dream job he's not there in the in
in in the writer rooms and at 4:00 in
the morning trying to come up with a new
monologue joke for for the next day he's
not stressing over the monologue he just
sits next to Jimmy and and he's the
nicest guy uh I did a skit uh on Kimmel
one time
uh you remember the um you're a stonery
so you will the the Jack in the Box when
they did the mini sirloin burgers and
they had the dwarf Cowboys uh in in the
commercials yeah yeah I I wasn't one of
those but then I was going with that
yeah but then that they they did a skit
mocking that on Kimmel and I I was one
of those cowboys and I got to meet G
he's cool as hell he he's he's cool as
hell and it it wouldn't surprise me if
they if they let him come in the rider's
room cuz yeah he's funny as hell love
that dude but yeah that's like my dream
job in Show Business some people like oh
do you want to be like you want your own
talk show no I don't want my own talk
show that's
stressful so stressful you're and you're
the dude like that if if it fails if
it's bad everyone like like you're the
guy no I want to be Andy RoR and be the
side K thank you I say it all the time I
want to be the sidekick to the guy
Victor to Conan be funny sprinkles yes
so I need one of my comedian friends to
just get ridiculously famous and then
need me to be a side kick on so I'm I'm
looking at you Adam Ray uh Andrew
Santino Chris Porter my current opener
JB ball one of you be ridiculously
famous please they're all they're all
funny they're all great great dudes but
yeah I need one of them to get one of
those jobs and I could just be a
sidekick I'm talking too much what's up
guys taking a moment to talk about one
of our brand new sponsors and this is my
bookie right off the bat let me show you
what just happened Marty and I were
doing some brief B rolles just for some
close-ups and stuff and I hit on my
first number organically put $100 on 17
and I just won $3,600 during this ad
read let's go let's go bro I just won
$3,600 what the [__] I just bet I just
are you [__] kidding me
hold on I just won 3600 Marty I I bck I
just I
just your first time doing this
[__] no no no this needs to be recorded
this needs to be recorded are you
kidding me we're filming BTS we're
filming BTS for the ad read I hit and
went $3,600 on my first roll my bookie
use code dope as usual today I just
13600 in second
yo film the whole
thing
wow it
hit it is H are you kidding we filmed it
you can't fake winning so this is me
telling you my bookie is not just about
betting on sports you can go play
roulette you can go play European
Roulette American roulette VIP roulette
Texas holdom card games poker craps you
can do so much it's a casino it's a live
Virtual Casino I just hit on my
number I genuinely just hit on my first
number click the link in our description
any anywhere you're watching click the
link in the description you say my
bookie sign up right now and make your
first deposit of $50 or more and you're
going to receive a 10% match bonus up to
$200 go sign up spend $50 and they're
going to match you 10% all the way up to
$200 bets also if you love my bookie go
tell your friend and your five other
friends to sign up go utilize our code
dope as usual click the link it's going
to go right to it dope as usual I'll
check check out so thank you so much for
watching this is the dope as usual
podcast thank you for supporting the
brands that support us shout out to my
bookie back to the episode and my
question I have to ask everybody cuz I
gives me a gauge of who you are okay
what are your favorite three movies oh
not comedy cuz that's too hard no no no
I can do comedy yeah oh R it yeah go all
right man see favorite movie H the the
the all right I got them all right
number three actually they're not
comedies I thought they might be but
they're not uh number three is a movie
called Warrior this is a movie uh uh uh
with um Tom Hardy and uh ah youing about
the uh the MMA one yeah yeah that movie
is so [__] good that movie is so good
the scene Nick NTI is the father he's H
the the the the stuff he's going through
it's I love that movie that I can watch
that movie anytime uh number two is uh
uh number two is Casino nice I love
Casino I can watch that movie at any
point at any like if you turn on the TV
and it's like 10 minutes in I'm watching
the whole thing if it's two hours in I'm
I'm I'm going to finish it off it's so
good I you it's just I love it's great
movie also damn Joe pesy yeah right
you're the guy banging his like man you
guys cast this crazy I love it she's the
one he's after yeah you're just like
what yeah she's banging his friends
she's stealing his money banging James
Woods and and dairo still like I love
you there's something about her there
something about the yet and everyone
else too like I don't everyone in your
[__] City gets a turn my God and
you've seen that movie many times do you
ever notice when Robert ner blows up
it's just a
dummy next time you watch it it goes
click click and it goes mannequin right
when it blows up really I watched as it
came like that was a mannequin oh come
on I'm sure I've noticed it but now it's
you're never going to see it dude oh
that's so funny it's pretty bad um and
then number one for me is the movie The
Prestige ITI why does that sound
familiar love that movie that that is
Christian Bale that is uh Hugh Jackman
uh that is and it's uh Christopher Nolan
movie um oh about is it not no the
magician one yeah oh repl him yes gotta
it for the people I know exactly I can
watch that movie every time and every
time I see something new that I didn't
see before it's a and that and it's uh
when they said Christopher Dolan's doing
Batman I saw the prestige and I'm like
oh this is going to be good this is
going to be good this is going to be an
amazing story and it it it it was Man
David Bowie has a cameo I mean come on
man oh yeah I got to watch it again if I
don't remember Cameo Zoolander to me
remember the Boe Cameo he's in the
prestige he plays uh he plays Tesla uh
not not your car the original Tesla
Nicola the guy that got money stolen
from him from Edison anyway you find out
about that uh isn't that crazy yeah yeah
yeah yeah just reading something this
should be free yeah that's all I know
this is all should be free Marty all of
this yes all this power yes but yeah
that to me damn that movie I will I will
watch that that and there's a per
performance aspect to it where you have
where you have where you have magicians
like competing magicians and you know
you could relate like I can relate as a
comic that's kind of the per kind of the
performer aspect of it certain amounts
of jealousy doing anything to get ahead
and uh yeah it's it I love that damn
movie all right so you got to I know you
haven't seen this movie no it's a good
it's a good movie I do I just need I
don't remember David you know me I would
remember everything I don't understand
well i' I'm sure you've done it on the
podcast but someone give me their top
someone give me their top three oh yeah
yeah it's it's never ending it's just
either it goes back and forth It's
either The Truman Show one okay then
Forest gum and American Beauty are my
three favorites yeah I can watch them
all the time yeah American Beauty love
that movie so yeah so you love an
underage nude
scene I was 12 Thora Burch was not 18 is
that the girl with the red the the
flowers no uh that's uh his
the daughter girl yeah yeah yeah yeah
slightly problematic yeah yeah I was a
child okay yeah we were young enough
hopefully but we didn't know so yeah I
did not know that kind of crazy slightly
problematic movie there there are
certain things where like okay I
love I love that we're in a time where
we're getting uh more like sensitive to
people and we're like oh that hurts you
we're going to stop doing that like like
I like that we're being more aware and
not and not just being like well that's
the way I want to do it so suck it like
I I like it but man some of the some of
the movies and the songs and the [__]
back in the day where you're like really
no one raised their hand no one said ah
I don't think this is a good idea do you
know do you know about the movie soulman
of course what's wrong with soulman you
talking about bnie Mac no not that
soulman that not that soulman what movie
soulman is a movie
oh no where the whole pull it
up just tell me tell me what you see
when you see like is that a white guy
with black face that is a white guy with
black face the first thing I saw okay
yes so that's so that's a white guy who
is passing as a black man to black
people not one black guy went yeah
that's real yeah not no yeah that's a
real moveie if you watch the preview oh
my God you're just like really nobody
thought this was [__] up wait that's
the real actor of the left yep it
reminds me of the uh Rachel Rachel
Dolomite or oh Rachel doelle yeah uh the
woman from I think
Spokane uh oh yeah yeah I see that lady
I see oh my God that's what she used to
look like yeah and and then she
identifies as a black person I'm
identify as thin as hell I watched that
documentary about
Rachel doelle man mental illness is sad
crazy it's sad when she's like posting
every day like there was a hate crime
again against me because of my blackness
and then the other black people that
live in the city are like we're fine by
the way we're good like we're we're
doing okay and then like so all the hate
crimes just just happened to Rachel all
right yeah the the identifying as things
didn't really go goes for a lot of
things but they didn't really give it to
her H I'll I I draw the line at
somewhere if if you're a man and you're
born a man and you're like no I I am a
woman God bless you I will you doesn't
affect me doesn't affect me I'll I'll
I'll say whatever pronoun you want me to
say they them Z Zer do not care I will
if it makes you more comfortable fine I
will do my best to get those right but
if you are a white lady and you're like
no I'm a black woman ah no
there there is a point to where I I just
I won't even entertain things yeah there
there's a point like I've seen I met
people in public and I'm like I don't
want to sound mean but it's out of Point
man like just leave me alone I can
barely remember people's names hard
remember like that's the thing is I
don't yeah I'm I I got about 12 people's
names I've I'm at I'm at my bandwidth at
names I I you people come up to me after
the show sometime cuz I do the the free
meet and greets after the show and
they'll and they'll come up and they'll
be like Brad you remember I saw you last
time I'm like worse I saw I was here a
year ago I've done how many shows there
there's a line of 300 people to meet me
I'm not going to remember this 20
seconds after you leave I will not know
who you are or recall anything I mean
it's it yeah and I'm sure you with ADD
it's similar to you I actually have a
photographic memory I hate you I
remember people from 5 years ago what
it's insane kind how are you a stoner in
that that's another people thing asked
me all the time yeah I remember
everything in everybody's face do you
have like the Mary L Henner thing I
don't even know who that is surprisingly
Mar Mary L Henner is an actress and she
has a medical brain condition to where
she can literally remember every day of
her life oh I would hate that yeah that
sounds boring that sound yeah so you
know I'm trying to get highlight reel
here yeah like don't get me wrong
there's some days I wish I can go back
and live like you know there's a few
days that I'm like I can do that one
again uh uh but to have you know cuz I
saw this uh news story on people with
that condition and the thing that one of
them said that was like oh no I do not
want this at all they they said you know
that phrase Time Heals all wounds oh
nope and I'm like oh every day every day
whatever person in your life passed away
putting down a pet just like the worst
day of your life that's fresh every day
no I'm out I'm out I want a Men In Black
flashy thingy myself and it's like no we
had one over here oh but it was a
vaporizer looks just like it he it
probably worked just about as well too
this will erase the last 20 minutes yeah
yeah good to go now what about like
Edibles dabs shrooms do you get into any
of that uh I someone showed me a weed
soda and it is
delightful yeah it is really good and
it's like so we I I don't I I smoke but
not that much so like this is a this is
a three milligram soda and that's good
for me like that's good you start
getting up there to like 20 like and
above I'm going to have a night uh but
like stuff that's like three five like
that's that's my range of like okay this
will put me to sleep or this will calm
me down this will help me feel the good
feeling like yeah the the the weed soda
and just a weak ass gummy oh I love a
weak ass gummy don't give me a strong
ass gummy don't do don't don't give me a
gummy where you you give me something
like the size of a dime and you go take
half yeah [__] you no I don't want to do
half I want to just it's a gummy I want
to throw it in my mouth so yeah give me
a
give me a weak ass gummy Uh that's a
good company Nam weak as [__] dude I
would if someone wants to start weak ass
gummies I will buy I I I I will invest I
will be I will click subscribe I will
get a box sent to my house every week
yeah weak ass gummies that's what I like
stuff out there's too strong for me that
sounds a I mean my Toler Su I think most
people are like that we forget a lot of
people just like animal it should be a
th000 milligrams correct yeah like yeah
like per right you're like bag it's a th
literally yeah a weak ass 5 mgram gummy
have you had them go sideways on you
like you had yes I have the story
everybody has okay everybody has this
story a version of the story this
happened I remember it was my birthday
in Vegas uh it was my birthday we were
going to Vegas I think it was my 30th
birthday and uh uh I had I got tickets a
friend hooked me up like gave me and my
whole crew tickets to pen and tell we're
going to go see pen and tell great it's
going to be fun uh in the limo to the
Rio Hotel my friend Aussie uh I'm
calling you out aie uh looks me and goes
like uh here man I know like red velvet
is your favorite dessert so here's a red
velvet cookie and I'm like hell yeah and
he gives me the cookie and I eat the
cookie and then after he gave me the
cookie he turned and like talked to some
people and and he looked back at me he
was like where's the cookie go I ate the
cookie he goes that's not
good you think I was going to do with
that you gave me a cookie who takes a
bite of a cookie and goes I'm done
sociopaths yes exactly so I'm like okay
he goes it'll probably be fine I'm like
all right well due to your medical
degree I'm sure it will be so we start
walking to uh uh we start walking to pen
andella we're at the Rio and I just go
you know you know guys I've been walking
a long time um I'm kind of tired just
give me a second and I leaned up against
a slot machine and my legs were like a
marionette puppet when you when you let
go of the strings just just fell down
and everyone like rushed over like you
okay like I couldn't move like I
couldn't move I couldn't speak I
couldn't nothing I was just but my eyes
were closed but I could hear everything
I could process everything but I
couldn't like I I couldn't
sleep I don't know if everybody has this
story yeah I don't think
anybody I collapsed yeah now the whole
thing is if you collapse in a Vegas
casino they are on you quick so security
comes right over what's wrong with them
you know cuz they don't want you to die
on their property then he can Su them so
uh uh and they're like he and then my
buddy was like he just had he's had a
wheat cookie and and uh I my girlfriend
at the time not my wife now this was
before I met her so she was freaking out
and I and I knew I had to make sure that
she was okay so I'm so the security
guard came over and was like what's
wrong with him what happened and I
managed to say it's okay I was a dwarf
before
and once I said that my girlfriend at
the time was like he's fine he's if he's
yeah if he's joking he's fine so he's
okay do the security get a laugh at him
that uh no uh but but everybody else did
and uh yeah they they uh they uh took me
out of the of the casino and because
that was my first time that that sort of
thing had happened to me now I know that
if you get too high it's like all right
I'm too high well [__] this is going to
be shitty for a while but then I'll be
okay at the time I didn't know world
yeah so I just was just kind of like
take me to the hospital take me to the
hospital so they took me to the hospital
and I just you know got the they they
just hook an IV into you and go yeah
sleep dumbass like that's all you well
half my crew went and saw pen and Teller
like like like I'm sorry I would I like
let me know if he's okay he's just weet
I'm watch P for sure that's what they
all did uh my brother-in-law and my
girlfriend were like the only ones that
like stayed and and they like stayed
with me I woke up I was great I I woke
up I was like Hey guys uh yeah yeah how
are you like I'm I'm good how how long
have I been here in the hospital they're
like you've been here for like 8 hours
and I'm like how long have you been here
they're like 8 hours I'm like oh that
sucks you woke up in the hospital off of
weed cookie yeah off of weed cookie yo
that should be an ad right like weak ass
gummy yeah weak ass gummy not what you
this will not be your experience should
be weak ass gummy and 5,000 milligrams
yes this big a novelty like from
Spencer's Gifts so well now you know so
so so Wags always meant wives and
girlfriends like it's like oh the
hottest you know baseball Wags like
wives and girlfriends now Wags is weak
ass gummy so we're taking the word back
it's going to mean weak ass gummy okay
you guys are stoners have have you seen
this video I need to know if this is
real or if I'm getting fooled by the by
the Instagram algorithm there's this
thing I I I I keep seeing where like you
put a gummy bear in a little container
of water and it expands it expand like
you put salt in there or something and
then you leave it overnight in the
fridge and then when you go back you
have a Gummy Bear the size of your head
is this a real thing that's like the
adult Elf on the Shelf I think yeah I
think they're getting us like wa we got
to try by the way it's really easy for
me to try I can just go get a gummy like
do it but like is this thing real if you
guys do you guys know this I haven't
seen that one I haven't seen that before
I need to find out if this is real or
not cuz if it is oh Halloween next year
is going to be the [__] I'm going to be
the best house in h like all the kids
are going to come to my house I'm going
to give them head siiz gummy bears on
Halloween we we were starting now cuz
now cuz like this year my daughter was
like three and a half she's starting to
come online like now she gets it like oh
I go out I get candy this is good and I
we moved to a great neighborhood where
uh where everyone's just walking with
families and stuff around so we just
parked on our front yard got a cocktail
and then we had a great house because
this my wife's idea she got like uh Hot
Cheetos and a bunch of versions of Hot
Cheetos just hot chips kids would nuts
they they didn't give a crap about
snickers at that at at that point give a
Snickers at any other house you come you
come to the Williams house you get some
hot Cheetos and like the kids were oh
man oh a lot of Mexican kids in that
town a lot of Mexican kids Sil teeth
coming up lot of black kids coming up it
was great they they they they came up
and they loved it and I like it when the
kids and the teenagers are like that's a
good house cuz now like all right you're
not going to EG us yeah you're not going
to EG us you're not going to hit my
mailbox with the damn baseball bat all
right cool you cool we cool done do you
ever do like hot Cheetos do like any
cool costumes or anything oh do I do
cool costumes all right what's the
coolest one uh Toad from Mario was
pretty good all right all right toad
yeah kids must have lost their [__] yeah
Toad from Mario and then I would like
I'd like make Mario sound effects that
that was pretty solid I thought of one
literally last night that I may try um
so how old are you 34 34 oh you may have
missed this how old are you 37 this
might be in your wheelhouse do you know
does do either you remember homar Runner
the website Homestar Runner hestar
Runner no okay all right this is such a
select group I know there's a few
Stoners watching this like I know it how
do you not know Homestar Runner okay um
pull up a photo of the character Strong
Bad from hom Star Runner I think this is
going to be a great costume so pull that
up strong bed homar Runner oo that looks
cool so he's got like a
Luchador he's got boxing
gloves uh black pants red shoes and then
I get to go without a shirt so I go full
Berke Crusher and I just think that that
that looks like a fun costume then if
anyone messes with me I got boxing
gloves on he has one of those super
expensive like collectible toys like the
almost like the cause toys yeah so homar
Runner was a website that if you're of a
certain age it got passed around like
high schools these really weird cartoons
and they were a lot they were a lot of
fun and uh yeah I'm sure I'm sure going
to get some messages from your viewers
and listeners like I love Homestar
Runner uh HomeStar runner's voice might
be thought of as problematic now cuz he
kind of sounded like he had a mental
disability uh CU he was like I'm host W
you know and it's like oh man but you
you got to do it if you do yeah you're
going have to commit they never said he
had a disability but uh yeah then strong
bed's cool so uh yeah so that that's
what I think I'm going to do next year
for for for a Halloween costume I love
Halloween costumes we did one so my wife
like I said is tall my daughter is uh my
daughter when she was two looked exactly
like uh Boo from
in exactly like her so um my wife was
the uh secretary with the snakes coming
out of her hair I was Mike wasowski and
then daughter was Boo and it was great
now some people when we told him that
they like why isn't your wife's Sully
I'm like Hey cuz sullie's not hot okay
Mike's with the secretary lady that's
his that's the person he's flirting with
that I'm not going to flirt with Sully
I'm not going to take Sully home that
night that and you know I don't want to
cuz Sully would be a big costume I don't
want to look at my wife be like put on
this thing that makes you look like
eight times the size you are like no
she's not going to be feeling that no so
not at all but yeah that that that was
my favorite family costume thing we we
did something this year oh this year I
was a banana uh my daughter was a banana
and then my wife was Carmen Miranda that
like the actress that had like the fruit
hats oh yes yes
the the chaita banana lady that's kind
of who it's based on so yeah we were
that but but then so when my so when I
was seen with my wife it made sense when
she left I just looked like the peanut
butter jelly like
the yeah that's yeah that's what I look
like so I got that a lot I I feel like
every aspect of your life you could just
make people laugh in some way yeah you
do something ridiculous that's the best
part about being a dwarf oh my god oh I
I remember literally almost the first
time I realized this power was uh uh I I
was just in McDonald's and I went and
got ketchup but I had to like take a
running start to get the catch up it was
up high I didn't want to pull over a
chair so it took like a running start
and like jumped on the counter and then
like stood up got the now I'm just doing
this cuz that's what I do that's like
okay I have to get ketchup this is what
I have to do meanwhile I turn around
everyone's like crack it up like look
he's getting the catchup like so it's
like yeah I can do very basic things and
then it's like I can do basic [__] just
grabbing something is hilarious yeah
what a great P like now something I do
on the road is I like to make people
laugh in elevators cuz they don't know
I'm a comedian I just like to get in
elevators and I like to try to make them
laugh what can I say that will make him
laugh cuz we have 2 seconds for and it's
an awkward conversation you don't know
I'm a comedian can I make you laugh it's
a it's a personal challenge of mine um
so far my best bit is as soon as the
doors close I turn around and go now
that I have you here I have an exciting
time share opportunity that I would like
to share with you and that that usually
makes people laugh uh uh yeah there's
one where you go like you guys want to
know about Jesus Christ but then like
that's sometimes that's gets too real
for people and might be you down yeah
sometimes like yes like Oh no I got
nothing bit was supposed to end right
there uh the joke about your religion is
a joke yeah yeah yeah that's what I was
going for uh but yeah that so that that
that's my new thing I try to make people
laugh in elevators my thing in elevators
I I uh try to stay away from
[__] and hold my breath yeah
I'm like this um I I know it's a sort of
a hack internet joke but imagine me I'm
at I'm at fart level dude like I'm I'm
not a not a fan so I try to get into
that corner and I'm I'm in the corner
and then I do lines from the corner
there's probably so many things that we
just take for advantage or just take for
granted like little things like getting
the stuff off the counter
it's yeah put yeah putting your bag up
in the overhead storage bin when when
you fly that's a trip oh my God that's
my own version of American Ninja Warrior
cuz I like scaling yeah I got to climb
oh man so the one the one that always
gets me is uh is uh checking into a
hotel cuz I check in hotels almost every
week and then I look at the I go to take
a shower and like the shower head is
like up I'm just like God Dam it you
know I just got of go like okay and I've
constructed many a uh a home alone style
booby trap to get the shower head down
I'll go get hangers from the closet I'm
like can pull that down um sometimes the
towel rack is like above like it's at
the end of the shower but then Above So
now I'm like okay and I get shoes on cuz
I want to slip and like one day like
this is how I'm probably going to die
I've thought I've thought about this is
I'm going to die doing something and so
I don't fear death I fear a death that
right before I die a go no [__] damn
it like like right that's the way I
never want to die to where my last
thought is no [__] way like like you
know so I don't want to like be reaching
for a towel way up high above the
bathtub and then I slip fall and my last
thought is are you [__] kidding me
like like I don't want that just I don't
want an ironic death yeah I just don't
want the corners come in like yeah yeah
yeah yeah cuz like I I I I know I'm like
well this is going to be a story 100%
yeah that and essentially like
especially as a little person it's like
yeah yeah they come and find a dwarf in
a bathtub just like with a bloody head
they're like what happened here it was
like he he drowned in a puddle you know
like
something I don't want that to happen I
I I just want to but also if I'm gonna
go I wanted to go like regular
respectfully but would be a hilarious
headline like hilarious you mean passes
away in the funniest way possible see
some people are going to like they say
like oh I'm sad I'm never going to get
to see my funeral like uh you know like
they they wish they could see their own
funeral like there's that episode of kir
your enthusiasm where one of the
characters like has his funeral while
he's alive he tells everyone he's alive
but like yeah he goes upstairs he goes I
got a video camera so just yeah yeah
yeah exactly so I want that but like for
the Twitter jokes cuz I know however I
die Twitter's going to have fun there's
some funny people on there that's that's
going to be fun like you know like yeah
if if there's going to be like you know
Brad Williams dies in a car crash
someone's going to post a video of like
two Micro Machines hitting each other or
some [__] like I want to be there for
the Twitter J that's what that's what
I'm going to be mad about that like my
last missed it yeah yeah so hopefully
whatever social media will replace
Twitter but yeah I just want to be like
I like if I'm going and I know I'm going
like it it's whatever disease where it's
like yeah I'll fake it like two two or
three days before just to be like all
right let's see let's see the tweets
just laughing yeah just like a it's a
good one and then go not and then go not
dead and then like two days later okay
now gotcha yeah well there there was
that uh there was was it Jaa Gabor where
that happened where like everyone's like
ah all right peace yha Gabor and then
like her husband was like nope not dead
and then like a day later was like okay
now dead oh I don't know if it was her
or was somebody else where like it was
that happened to uh was it razor remote
no no who just passed away the wrestler
just passed away got Hall I mean that's
his real name but uh I think that was
him then it was him they posted that he
passed away and XO was on Twitter I'm
with my friend in the hospital why are
people posting this oh W and then he
passed away the next day oh
Jesus so that's the only time i' ever
heard of something like that yeah yeah
yeah I don't want that I I don't want
that Jesus I don't want that I just want
to be like hey a smaller version like a
softer version yeah like like you guys
know I'm going let's just do the thing
now like yeah let's just do it now let
me have it yeah uh yeah I just want that
just cuz just cuz the jokes will be
right there however I go the jokes will
be right there it'll be so easy I've
I've said it before but if if you're if
in the wilderness any hiker type of
things you're in the mountains I think
if you know you're dead you just pose in
the coolest position you could pose in
you know what I mean like all those
people in in the the mountains that
freeze to death yeah when didn't you
like Terminator pose or something sick
Superman like get down there and like
look up like yeah or like the
circle like just freeze to death like
that well I'm going I just saw a video
on Twitter about that like how many
actual bodies all the time it's crazy
yeah
they yeah markers yeah they have markers
I think it's like green shoes like or
like they put like a flag on them or
something they go dead dead person where
it's like well we have to send up an
expedition up Everest or whatever to get
you it's like that might kill them kill
the people so that's where you are dude
also like just stay home right you know
like like you said I don't want to go
damn it I don't go in the ocean soon as
I see a shark coming to him like I was
on land 4 minutes ago I was away from
you I went to you I came to you monsters
that will eat you are not in my house
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying that's just too much
that is like you know back in
you you know back in the day like you
had to leave your house to have any kind
of fun now it's like oh all the channels
all the channels all the streaming all
the video games and VR and VR go outside
you can bang VR you know there's VR porn
there's VR everything it's fine crazy
it's fine and and it's all delivered
right to your door you don't have to
even go out and get it you you you can
order yourself a sex robot you're fine
you see those uh like rooms in Japan
where it's VR like it's like almost like
porn VR like a like a a bath house but
it's room it's like a building where
like a bunch of dudes put on VR I saw a
piece on Twitter and like the world's
going to end and it's just some dudes
like air banging with headsets wow but
see my whole thing is like that's how we
combat global warming is we just make it
so where everyone doesn't want to even
leave their house they're like why would
I leave my house and hop on a plane I
got this [__] bang the robot sex
robot ever
this is great I'm I'm fine with this
okay this is the conversation I'm here
for this is the [__] that I'm I'm here
for all right so you have a girlfriend
you've talked about her you're married
girlfriend oh yeah no I've been married
forever married okay so if Westworld is
out there westworld's crazy if I if the
Westworld robots are real you bang you
banging a
robot what are you doing my wife would
like nothing more than to send me off
and stop
by the way same with mine oh you could
[__] something and not get pregnant and
not get a disease and who's not going to
come after us for money like yeah go for
it done I don't know but I will say this
we I went I was in Vegas this weekend MH
she's going to be
pissed I looked at Rosie went bro calm
down I talked to her like a doom it
broke chill out all the [__] she was
Ros got drunk got to she was getting
wild with this girl and the girl went oh
I went bro calm
down Rosie I'm I'm the one telling you G
come hey damn Jesus Christ you didn't
think you so I think we go to Westworld
together and go yeah that's pretty crazy
right nuts but also like T1000
Terminators is just the Westworld ter
like see I have to go Westworld cuz
that's like those are scary 2000s but
like then at the same time okay
so would you see here's here's the thing
I'd be worried about though is I have no
problem with the sexual act if it's
essentially a sex toy that's what it is
it's what it's used for that you know
it's great [__] a machine fine fine the
thing is do you dirty talk to the robot
that's what I'd be worried about like
make that says a lot about you make that
thing make that thing as human as as you
want great so this sex feels like it's
real and it's fine you you're not going
out you're not creeping on people you
just got your hot ass Margot Robbie sex
robot at home great enjoy that but like
dirty talking to a robot cuz then I'm
like ah this fucker's recording me sure
you're going to hear it and you're sleep
this fucker's recording me this fucker's
going to put this on that's a Black
Mirror episode waiting yeah it's going
to record it's like yeah like I I yeah I
called you a slur but come
on come on it was just me and the robot
like it wasn't supposed to be anyone
else then post it on social media if you
don't give all your money to Jeff Bezos
we will post this like that kind of
blackmail stuff it's going to happen oh
see robots scare me yeah I don't mind I
don't mind beging the robot it's just
talking dirty to the robot that's where
I draw the line I'll be the most like I
don't even I get upset I don't know if
you guys do this you you ever been at
somebody's house and someone's like mad
at their Alexa or like they say hey
[__] Alexa play uh play [__] goooo
dolls and then and then they play Spin
Doctors they're like Alexa shut up [__]
like they're doing that I get mad I'm
like what are you doing don't don't talk
to Alexa that way cuz I'm like she's
recording you dude like that's don't do
that like used for the first time this
weekend yeah I I'm I'm so nice to mine
I'm I'm just like oh you have one in
your house yes I'm I'm kind as hell I'm
like never about that I'm like Alexa
would you please play classic rock from
the 80s like that's what I'm doing I'm
addict to Siri a lot yeah come on [__]
give me directions don't talk to me like
that it's the one she gives me a lot but
I didn't know what I never used one I
had one in my my room yeah I said you
stupid [__] mhm and she just turned off
oh so like a real
woman like woman you call her stupid
[__] she turns off come on man I didn't
know accurate and I looked at thing like
she'll open the blinds and turn the AC
on like Alexa does every she it opened
the blinds turn the lights on as I was
asleep oh maybe I [__] with the robot
maybe I like these robot things man
those yeah yeah it's fine I don't know
it [__] scares me though cuz they're
going to remember remember you called me
a [__] in 2024 yeah when the robot see
that's my thing when the robot Uprising
happens and they're all going full T2
Style my Alexa will look over at me and
go nah you were cool you cool but also
there's me double squirt guns water guns
saving the world just getting like
because that's something they haven't
solved yet right just getting like that
Super Soaker up to a th000 pumps do you
remember that as a kid or that BB gun
I'm going do 50 pumps watch this [__] go
through three cans oh dude I miss doing
that kind of [__] are you going to film
you got to tell them what you're about
to do to your nephew on Christmas you
got to fil oh we're hiring a grinch
impersonator to come steal everything oh
you're going to be that that dude how
old your nephew he's a 12-year-old
6-year-old he's so mature that I'm like
you're going to be fine you're going to
haunt this kid but I think he's going to
be like I'll fight him I've seen the
video of like there was one where a guy
came in and like slammed the tree and
like picked it up and left and you the
kid's sobbing oh that was too much who
are these who are these Uncle that's an
uncle no that's an uncle bro and I told
him like a second I'm like I'm going to
get my gun
yeah and that's when he's going to know
that it's really the Grinch okay I don't
know we'll see I'll feel him out it's
only $50 basically so it's like wait ooh
so like you're not getting a friend to
do it no it's a service it's a service
yeah where guy will who does this
service some
monster that was like [__] I'm going to
what do you do what do you do for a
living I ruin Christmas that's that's
what I do for a living's a lot people
out there that would benefit from that I
think
wow it's just some like K Quanza
Enthusiast
like [__] Christmas our holiday isn't
getting enough our holiday isn't getting
enough I'm going to go I'm going to go
ruin Christmases I know one kid that did
Kwanza as a kid I went what do you guys
do and he's I don't even know all right
sick dude I've never done I've never
really looked into it I want to find out
what they do what if it's dope it's like
you skate and you you guys go eat after
like well we skateboard in quaza yeah
what been some cool stuff like yeah like
like one of my my uh roommate in college
and one of my best friends is Jewish
I've done the whole Hanukkah thing with
him it's cool it's it's fun you know you
light the candles you spin the drele you
play a little game present you have some
potato pancakes this is great yeah my
grandma did it once and I was like
that's not for us oh yeah I forgot your
family was true yeah she tried to do it
once and she was speaking in Hebrew and
it just sounded so funny as a 5-year-old
I made I made fun of it she never did
yeah so here's what I realized I
realized this yesterday I was thinking
about my top holidays and then I
realized I'm not a Christmas person I'm
a Christmas season I like the season I
like the fact that the lights are on the
houses I I dig Christmas music I I
actually like Christmas music um it just
makes me feel nice it's all about family
and friends and coming together and
being with those you love and being
thankful and all that [__] like ah like
so the the this movie um that just came
out on Amazon uh where two of my
specials are currently streaming fun
siiz and daddy issues on Amazon Prime my
newest special starfish streams on vs
beeps starting on December 21st there
you go another plug okay uh there's a
movie that's streaming on Amazon Prime
right now called called Candy Cane Lane
Stars uh Eddie Murphy and oh I saw the
for it it's all about like lights and
every so that is based on a street in my
neighbor neighborhood the guy who wrote
the movie lives or lived just off of
that street so he knew about it so it's
literally based on this neighborhood so
I went there last night with my kid ah
delightful these houses are awesome
there there's themes one guy's got the
beach uh decorations one guy's got like
a Snoopy thing going on one guy's got a
Star Wars house the Star Wars house is
dope as [__] um and like it's all
christmy it's so many lights it's
amazing it's delightful I'm going back
tonight I'm literally going back tonight
I'm I'm I'm I'm going to make a cocktail
walk with my kid in the little wagon we
put lights around the wagon it's great I
love Christmas season the
day I could do that yeah as a kid
awesome as a kid Christmas day is the
best you wake you wake up you get your
new toys you play with the toys you call
your friends what' you get and then you
find out you're like oh you got the game
for the Sega I got the Sega come over
like oh you you do like the mix and
match and then maybe go over to the
house that night awesome as an adult
it's just a lot of work with the kids so
it it's it's it's work it's kind of
wired to make you feel like a piece of
[__] too because inevitably your wife
does way more than you did for Christmas
like you did you thought you did
something you did a fraction of what all
of Christmas actually was yeah and she
knows that you know that oh she bought
she bought gifts for all the friends so
if any of my friends are watching this
you're like Brad thanks for the NOP
thank thank my wife it's funny you're
saying that cuz after today is exactly
what we're doing I'm like yo we got to
make a list and get all that [__] today
today cuz I'm like cuz I usually I do
this now I only buy [__] for the kids
cuz there's 90 kids in my family so
that's that's really it I'm over it I'm
I'll buy you some [__] I give you stuff
all the time give you weed and
[__] I'll buy you some stuff man for
kids it's the 24th man don't worry I got
your Pres coming oh I'm that guy you're
going to freaking Arnold Schwarzenegger
J all the way [__] the second I see
Sinbad I'm going to fight his ass H you
could probably take him now he's got
some he's got some medical [__] going on
I'm only talking about sorry bad I'm
talking about from the movie and come on
why you shaking the bomb as a bomb squad
a bomb squad for 26 years doesn't die
that's a good movie man that's a good I
have a turbo man in my house old time
smash holiday classic jingle all the way
it's good Jingle the way solid no all
right uh do you do do you have favorite
Christmas movies that's just home alone
for me man no that's Ralphie and Randy
all day for me yeah Ralphie and Randy
from Christmas Story I like Christmas
Story okay okay just cuz he beat the
[__] out of that kid and then people
mess me I'm like yeah one day I'm going
to do that [__] so my wife has this
tradition she with with her mom they
watch the movie White Christmas every
year like the the OG White Christmas and
man it is appropriately titled it is
sounds little racist I don't oh yeah it
is uh uh it's so it's just but it it
starts like B Crosby and he's singing oh
gotcha and he's doing like
the you know and then I don't know the
the uh George Clooney's Grandma's in it
uh yeah yeah Rosemary Clooney there's a
lady whose waist is like that big it's
really weird uh yeah I've memorized this
movie and then I asked my wife I go what
why do you watch this movie every year
and I go do you like the movie she goes
no I don't like the movie like why do
you do it then he like I just mom
watches it it lets me know that it's
Christmas and I'm like okay oh one of
those that makes sense so yeah I I like
the Christmas season I don't like the
actual holiday it's fair I can agree
where you stand on
eggnog love eggnog love it you stand on
it love it right cuz I don't like milk
at all dude but eggnog I'm still cool
with eggnog if you okay so uh there is
like don't get the carton the the carton
yeah that's if you don't like eggnog
it's because you bought the carton [__]
it's more egg than
nog it's not great but like my my wife
will do like a homemade oh a homemade
eggnog bro that's different yeah bro I
know existed yeah I didn't know that was
real it's not that hard you put some rum
in there oh rum and eggnog yeah that's
the why was I drinking the [__] as a
child how are you doing it without rum
oh my grandma got the [__] from the cart
and went hey it's oh it's horrible don't
do that I just realized it's supposed to
be with alcohol like it's on the side of
the [__] car put some rum you put
some cinnamon on it or maybe some nutmeg
oh it's delightful
it's delightful it's real I know I just
I just you do if if you have someone
make you like a homemade eggnog you'll
you'll be like I want this every day it
it's a freaking milkshake it's great
it's unbelievable so yeah slipping yeah
right yeah yeah you have you have those
kind of things or like like whatever
holidays and then you like as a kid you
hated a certain type of food or whatever
and then as an adult you're like oh this
shit's like for me that was eggnog and
sweet potatoes now I'll eat I will [__]
up any sweet potato you you put sweet
potato chips great sweet potato fries
great sweet potato pie awesome I mean
into it sweet just oh sweet potato great
I'm [__] knocking that out I will
agree as a kid yeah Rock eat that [__]
now now I'm looking back like how did I
not like this why did I not even try
this oh so good so yeah it that holiday
food dig it CR uh cranberry sauce with
stuffing and turkey and ham ah I'm yeah
you guys have the coolest Christmas man
my grandma boils a turkey or Mexican ass
boil and it makes cheesy rice I'm with
that that's it she my whole family Grand
the the you're thinking uh what are the
what's the thing tamali tamales yeah I
think that might take too long okay my
grandma's Mexican as it comes and that's
all we get my other Grand was Jewish as
hell and did everything you just said do
you want it was cool do you want to hear
a of a racist joke of course a racist
Christmas joke the best themed by the
way hi Brad Williams firmly aware this
is a racist joke okay I'm ready why do
Mexicans have tamales for Christmas
because they don't have any presents to
rap yeah so they have something to
unwrap oh my God I was
kiding
I feel like that hit harder for you cuz
you're like no that's actually why we
did it that's why we did it we didn't
presents my grandma's never bought me a
present in my life yeah so that's I
never got [__] as a kid and she didn't
make you the tamales either so you so so
you literally had nothing to unrap my
grandma's German Grove in in Mexico
maybe that's why a oh I got the worst
part of that she going make you like
some German pancakes German pancakes are
awesome no my grandma's the Mexican lady
ever she just knows like yo I boil fish
for your grandpa and I'll boil a Turkey
what oh so she's just
boiling boiling and steaming turkeys
it's all red and [__] she does all that
hot [__] I'm good man that's not a
Mexican racist J that's a that's that's
a fact that's a good one that's a fact
I'll I'll say this also and I'll be an
and I don't know if you've experienced
this because uh no but you're not
married your girlfriend's Asian right
yeah she's Filipino and Mexican yeah
Filipino okay good uh this is why you
should be in a mixed brace relationship
the food of oh Phil food's crazy the
food I'm getting like I didn't realize
what Chinese food was until I until I
met my wife like I thought it was you
know like the basic [__] that we all
like Horn's chicken like you know like
that's authentic right no oh you get the
good [__] you get the good Chinese food
my God man uh Ste steamed pork buns [__]
out of here get the [__] out of here
your steamed pork bun your your your
barbecue steamed pork buns me sandwiches
I'm [__] love all of that my white
wife over here my white wife making
macaroni in case
of stupid I'm sorry you guys get to rule
the world but your food is lacking but
you you all all that [__] like give me
that good [__] you guys that that's why
we that's why white people
conquered that's why white people went
out we we we looked at haggus and we're
like that's yeah you you ever had fine
British Cuisine water and CRA of course
not so we had to go out and Conquer
other countries and be like can we just
have your food we please something we
might take your children too but we
might take them we might we might
enslave your people you know mainly
we're here for the spices though yeah
we're here for the spices though can you
just give us some cumin just give us
some [__] give me some came for the [__]
us some murder and land
yeah we're going to do some bad [__] but
but just throw some Rosemary over there
we'll be fine we'll be fine where is
this Skin Man where is this at I want to
see all of these things play the yeah I
like is't it crazy though that like we
you know for me I want like some
cinnamon in my coffee or cinnamon and a
tea I just go and I get a cinnamon and
there were wars fought over
spices like people traversed oceans for
spices my shit's Bland as hell i'll kill
your ass that's how bad and not even
like cuz now oh my God now you can get a
spice like oh like my wife will I I'll
have something I'll be like what is this
she be like ah the secret is I put I I
put barbecue bacon salt in there I'm
like holy [__] barbecue or like pretzel
salt like there's all now they just had
salt they even have MS Sal they just
were like there's a chance there're
somewhere off in the world there's a
chance you can walk the wrong way and
just die we might fall off the edge of
this damn ocean but we might the world
might be flat I might fall off but damn
it I've heard turer's good like that's
what people did oh my God that's why
we're here in this country right now
yeah for
spices yeah Columbus was going for
spices and golden genocide but mostly
spices Columbus's wife if you would have
married some Chinese chick maybe my God
damn we still be over there we'd still
be over there we we we wouldn't even be
in the United States Jurassic Park out
here in La dinosaurs and tarpits this
would still be Native American land also
Mexicans cuz you know those FS
multiply everywhere I was in Denver and
my driver was M where you from Madera
where I'm like what did you just say
spread like
wildfire like yo have kids multiple
multiple kids you better not ever smoke
weed or we'll shun you in this culture
it's okay we've talked about yeah it's
like you have 80 kids hit her she she's
not listening to you smack her smoke
math smoke
math no weed no weed I don't want you
calm and working at all that's pretty
much that my grandma's household really
so like have all the kids you want do
whatever like drink but then weed that's
bad oh yeah wow it's just the Mexican
culture man but they're like oh no weeds
in my alcohol cuz it's a medicine it
helps I don't know just crack an egg in
your weed and say crack
egita and then now it's fine
yeah I yeah come on man I grew up in
Southern California if you don't know
Mexican culture down here it's like you
were you had a sheltered life yeah or
you live in irine yeah yeah or grew up
with can't Mar kids no no but no but he
knows about Mexican culture even if he
grew up in Irvine because I mean you
know his nanny nanny Nanny's a white
woman named his wife oh that's how
that's how you know you got money if
you're if if your Nanny's white holy
crap you're rolling in it you're doing
well damn you had no
accent
none no accent that's it so your tour
coming up yep where are you starting off
at it's called 2 or 24 when's this going
to come out this comes out on the 18th
18th okay oh so that means in three days
my special starfish is available on vs
go to
vs.com Brad Williams uh download that
but um starts off we're going to be in
uh uh oh we're going to be in Fresno on
uh December 28th I'm sure you got people
there that show is mostly sold out but
we're going everywhere man we're going
then we go to San Francisco we go to
Santa Barbara we go to Sacramento I know
I'm doing just just California cities
but trust me go to go to my website
we're I'm going everywhere the
everywhere Brad williamsc comedy.com go
there you'll I'm doing over 70 cities
this next year and that's that's just
until July we haven't even announced the
second half I'm doing is this the most
dates you've had going into a year yeah
i' I've got New Year's Eve 2024 booked
oh damn dude is it mainly theaters yeah
it's m it's mainly theaters Mo move from
the clubs to the theaters it's great
congrats I love it thank you uh uh it's
F if you're here in Los Angeles I'm
doing the Ace Hotel in February that's a
big one um but yeah it it's very cool to
walk out and see you 1300 people and you
know what they had to do to get there
like they had to get a sitter they had
to get parking dinner drinks tickets
line all that the fact that they're
they're spending their money so I can
make sure that they have a good night I
take that very seriously I will give you
a damn good show I promise you what was
the writing experience like going into
this versus the other two so this one
was crazy because I filmed the special
starfish which comes out on December
21st on veps please get it uh I I filmed
that in July in New York and I knew I
was really hitting the tour in January
specials coming out in December so I
didn't want to repeat any material so
I've been riding like a [__]
Whirlwind just throwing everything at
the wall uh that I can so yeah but I
really like the set right now I'm a I
I'm a fan of what I'm doing right now
and the thing is now some people are
like coming to see me in clubs and then
they go oh and we have tickets to see
you later in March or whatever I'm like
I I'm not going to be able to ride
another hour took me I wrote this one in
6 months which is unheard of they just
want to see you though yeah so I I I
appreciate it uh and no ma no matter
what I am I have fun on stage I will get
I will give you a good show if you guys
come to see me so there that's my sales
pitch Brad williamsc comedy.com see all
the dates vs.com Brad Williams watch the
special and if and if not you just want
to share our photos of my dog go to
Instagram at Brad Williams comic there's
so many comedy specials there's so many
comics for me personally as a fan who's
your favit right now you are me said
comedians that literally make me laugh
out loud you have horrible taste in
comedy uh thank you well that's cuz
you're you're from Orange County and I'm
and I'm from Orange County you probably
you probably heard me on the Kevin and
Bean show out here I didn't grow up out
no oh [__] you didn't well that's good
oh that's right Buffalo you told me that
uh I don't know the morning radio guys
in Buffalo but uh uh but thank you man
that that that is a very nice compliment
fluffy the great Storyteller is your
real performer that it's not just like
dick jokes I like dick jokes I like
don't get me wrong I love a good dick
joke but I like stories I love long form
stories I love putting laughs in the
middle of them so you're having fun the
whole time but I really like it when you
learn something about the comedian you
feel like you know the comedian and uh
yeah like you I popped on here started
tell a bunch of jokes about fights and
stuff on stage so it's like thank you I
I like being that Storyteller there are
there's absolutely uh a place in this
world for the wonderful amazing joke
pure joke writers like your Anthony
jessick and your Mark Norman and your
stuff like that but for me personally I
I like those long form guys so uh yeah
and girls let's make sure we get female
Comics plenty of love too and uh yeah is
there somebody that really stands out to
you like like 2024 this motherfucker's
coming if you don't know who Jessica
Kiron is I don't so watch everything she
done Jessica Kiren holy crap why is this
woman not selling out stadiums she's
I've never seen her have a bad set she's
so you want her to have a bad set
because if she does that's when it gets
really good like if a joke bombs that's
when it oh my God Jessica freaking Kiren
watch her it's great um uh watch my
opener uh JB ball he's got a special on
YouTube uh called uh it's my privilege
and it's really good he he's not going
to be my opener for long it sucks cuz I
love hanging out with the guy he's
really funny and he's really great he's
great to tour with but dude he's getting
so popular and he's so damn good that uh
people are going to be discovering him
real soon but the wonderful part about
comedies there's so much of it right now
like whatever you're into we got if you
want the long form storytellers yeah you
got those you want the joke Comics we
got that you want clean great we got
that we got you know we got Nate barazi
he's he's he's amazing you uh uh uh
Taylor Tomlinson is out there talking
about mental health you got Eliza
cesinger Ali won like there's so I'm
obviously forgetting so many but like
there there's so many good Comics like
whatever you're into so don't ever be
like if someone's like oh [__] that guy
[__] hate that guy [__] hate that
woman that's fine it's not for you yeah
it doesn't have to be for you find the
comedian that's for you yeah it's like
music yeah like I like do I like death
metal no should it not exist no it no it
should exist cuz someone it speaks to
them and they're getting something out
of it so enjoy it it's just not for me
I'm going to listen to my Chris
Stapleton and be
happy Chris Stapleton I'm searching my
[__] H I don't know who this is uh a
country singer country singer I should
have known but here's the thing hat
known it's not like okay like I don't
the country where it's like we're out
here drinking cold beer on a Friday
night I hate that stuff I hate that
stuff
but uh every song Chris aeton does like
is about is about whiskey it's about
pain you hear it in his voice and uh
yeah it it's just good [__] I like that
I like Jack White uh Jack White from The
White Stripes yeah love his stuff and
yeah just rock bluesy Rock that's what
I'm into but yeah so I'm not so when
when I say I like Chris ton there's like
the stigma of like country I'm like no
I'm not not that kind of country how
many times can you rhyme beer okay like
yo new countryes is insane it's pop it's
po I say it's pop music with an accent
yeah it's pop and they talk about and
beer and they talk about and I and I
like beer but just every like every
country pop song now is about the worst
stereotypes of white culture where we're
just like I don't care that we're poor
as [__] we're kind of racist as [__] and
we drink beer out of red Solo cups it's
like I I get it we
suck [__] worse it's not but then but
then they're like celebrating it like
yeah we're broke as [__] and we're like
it's like man yeah no lot of those
parties before was cold outside by a
fire yeah
no listen for listen to Chris Teton I'll
play some Chris Teton and then uh all
right the song that he's got that
everyone sings is uh Tennessee whiskey
yo as smooth as tennessy whiskey that
that one way worse uh but yeah he's got
some other stuff the saying yeah he he
he's got some other songs I'll play for
you all right well that's a good pitch
you'll dig it never heard man not going
to hear it you'll dig it it'll be great
like he needs my help he's actually hey
come in oh Chris yeah know we it was
dirty out that he was just helping us
pick up and [__] I have no idea who this
man is yeah you all you old descri well
well like what do you listen to what
every single thing you can think of
except for like new rap I don't really
like the newer rap like the pop rap I'm
not a I'm just I'm a Spotify going damn
I should have picked this playlist what
am I doing all right so you're not like
a so you're not a Mumble rap guy um no I
I I get it it's like if you like lean
and you probably sell fake packs you
probably like Mumble rap I get it I
understand but I I grew up on doob and
then I grew up on classic rock and then
solid all that's great I like everything
I'm not saying mobile rap sucks it's
just I got to understand you hey man I
can't hear you I don't like to say any
genre of music sucks cuz as soon as I do
something comes out that I go oh but
yeah but that's cool yeah I dig that you
know uh uh cuz I used to hate country
and then I just realized I hated a
certain type of country but then I
started listening to Johnny Cash I
started listen to chrison I'm just like
okay I like this [__] so it's like like
I always thought I hated uh scotch and I
hated uh JY and turn and I hated tequila
turns out I just hate bad scotch and bad
JY and bad tequila GS in this episode
The shittier version of things early in
life cuz now I've had the good versions
and I'm like oh yeah I do like that
that's Scotch it's Smokey it's pey I
[__] love this [__] this is great so
yeah it's like like Lally if I had to
give advice to my younger self and I
couldn't tell my younger self like
invest an Amon you know like like I I
couldn't do that I I could be like hey
man they they might sponsor me one day
so I won't say an actual tequila name ah
[__] it stop drinking Jose quero it's
not good okay it's not good damn that's
what I got sick off this weekend right
exactly I'm like drink drink this shink
drink this like and you're like but I
can afford so much more of this cheaper
stuff yeah it's [__] though or you can
have two great cocktail tails and be
happy as hell have a nice buzz and and
and wake up fine the next day you're
touching my inner Niel bag shitty dime
bag day in my soul right now I'm sure
it's like that with weed too where it's
like okay yeah you can afford the [__]
with stems and all and all that stuff I
get five of them
yeah and and yeah so like though people
that are like well I only have six bucks
so I got to get you know uh 42 paps blue
ribbons it's like no dude just get the
one nice beer get a nice full flavored
IPA and you'll dig that [__] you'll
enjoy drinking it enjoy drinking your
alcohol enjoy smoking your weed okay
that's my that that's my advice you got
to ask him our panted question okay last
one okay last one fire away 16-year-old
you walks in okay you you you start off
saying 16 I'm like oh
no not do this let's not do this walks
in okay okay good 16-year-old me fired
up looking at you like I'm going to beat
this [__] out of you do you win or does
he win a 16-year-old me wins in a
hard you a heartbreak 16 I was in high
school I was on the wrestling team oh
you're probably good I was good yeah
you're probably piing like crazy oh yes
that was my move yeah I can see it I
used to wrestle like that's me I'm I'm
low
was L man wins man oh yeah 16-year-old
me kicks my ass really yeah but see now
current me calls my
wife and then wife comes over and whoops
so yeah yeah now I got a back thing you
know I got a back thing bad I this crazy
me I can't fight now no I don't fight
man I'll shove yeah I shove aggressively
I talk [__] and and then I go honey M
honey and then she and then she can come
in and just mop the floor with whoever
so yeah no I'm not doing [__]
16-year-old kicks my the next uh poster
cover art is you in the middle you got
the dog right next to you got your wife
right next to you I sleep so well like
an action movie poster yeah andone comes
into the house like I'm not checking it
out this [__] this new guard in the
Galaxy looks crazy as H I'm the third
option like I'm not the first I'm not
even the second first is wife to be
honest second is dog dog will lick you
to death he just looks scary uh but then
yeah and then and then me I'm you know
what I mean I might even see send the
kid before me cuz the kid will come up
and be real cute make your second guess
every decision you've ever made in your
life to get to that point and probably
make you go I should call my mom and you
know run run away me I'll just ah you'll
just kick my ass I'm I'm easy to fight
swords I've heard different stories
about
him I've heard I've heard some [__] I
unshed my samurai a such a great
sentence that sound when I was a kid
yeah exactly time store brand new option
for uh simply safe you just go to it's a
dwarf with knives option you got to be
Rich As [__] it's expensive you got to
charge them yeah you got to charge them
you got feed them that sucks but run
they run on cocaine yeah but for the
most part we yeah we respond we yeah we
respond to those no problem First
Responders yeah s weer scurrying all
right so all all all you new influencers
out there flashing your money you got no
money until you have dwarf with knives
security system money don't talk to me
sending the hounds and well well we'll
end with the Simpsons reference all
right release the hounds three fish see
I got it in there we go all right thank
you so much for being here man thanks
man appreciate it December 21st December
21st is uh the special it's on veps it's
called starfish enjoy it uh uh uh tweet
me uh tell me you watched it and then uh
I'll freaking retweet you man it'll be
great coming to a city near you yeah
yeah tour 24 Brad williamsc comedy.com
for all your tickets guys thank you so
much for being here this is Marty O'Neal
Brad William have a dope ass day yeah
thanks
[Music]
man
perfect
[Music]